I got to see the film on IMAX last night
what a great way to see this film and
here this film and feel this film you
really get every single piece of the
movie
I got fast you need to see everything my
goal with the movie was to take
advantage of all the spectacle that a
movie like this could offer particularly
on IMAX screens and at the same time
that you're drawn in you care about
these characters I really genuinely
liked both of those characters just as
an observer on the outside I find it
quite liberating playing a real
character and especially when there's
someone is really fascinating there's
you Kent models it was nice to bring
this story to the screen because I
didn't know it and it's a great story
it's strange that we don't know it
actually because it's such an
interesting story it said for it makes
healthy little cars and gods you faster
through such an interesting battle
between these two companies and their
different aesthetics their different
cultures
go ahead Kel go to war we're gonna marry
Ferrari at LeMond I think the first
thing that happens in IMAX when you see
a film in IMAX is you have a brilliant
projection system and one of the things
let's held back digital projection for
years is that the contrast the luminance
of the screen was never as intense as it
was when you're projecting real film but
with the new laser projectors and IMAX
uses it certainly is
also you know IMAX has its own
proprietary sound system so the racing
sequences the sound effects the sound
design the music the the immersive sense
at all is fantastic and IMAX what I
really wanted to do in this film was
trying to put you behind the wheel so
you're really feeling not only the speed
but what they're facing the tactics
they're using to defeat the other
drivers to battle the own weaknesses
their car their own exhaustion whatever
personal baggage they've carried into
that car that day I want you to feel
that
if you watch Ford versus Ferrari on your
phone you haven't watched Ford versus
Ferrari enjoy on the big screen this is
a movie really that is made for the big
screen IMAX is the way to see it
you
you